das hier ist der perfekte Sommerdrink
und ihr braucht drei Zutaten und einen
Mixer in den geben wir Limetten Minze
und Basilikum die Limetten sind ganz mit
Schale deshalb wichtig Bio Deckel drauf
und Knallgas
Eis dazu und ordentlicher gabendicksaft
für die süße wenn ihr nicht so süß wollt
nehmt nicht so viel wenn ihr süß wollt
dann nehmt viel Glas nehmen Minze rein
ein Sieb und durch das Sieb schütten wir
unseren Sirup hinein jetzt nur noch mit
Sprudelwasser auffüllen Deckel drauf
Strohhalm rein wow wir probieren
unfassbar erfrischend nicht so süß eine
leicht bittere Note perfekt deshalb
würde ich sagen